sometimes I think that people are just
ideas like what if God had an idea right
and I say God in the ethereum the you
can whatever God you want I have my you
you can have your own God I think of
people sometimes as like an idea of God
like say you have an idea write an idea
kind of comes in it comes into like it
comes out of kind of nowhere right
like if you have an idea in your head
it comes out of nowhere
and some some ideas there they do they
they stick around they they turn into
something some ideas they make a
difference they some ideas really get
turned into something and can adjust the
world can adjust something small or as
big as the whole world you don't know
how big an idea can be or how far an
idea can go right
if we have an idea
so sometimes I think that humans they're
just ideas
of God really you know
it's like we show up in existence
we have a purpose sometimes sometimes we
don't
sometimes we evaporate and disappear
early you know
sometimes we stay around for a long time
sometimes we change our environment
uh and sometimes we we can change the
world you know
so I don't know if this is making sense
but
I feel like life it's like being a lot
it's like we're almost like an idea of
God
like if we have an idea it comes into
fruition we do things with it some of
them are really helpful some of them
kind of come and go
but if God when God has an idea that's
us that's a person we're his idea we're
like ideas of God we come into life we
meander
some sometimes we have an effect on
things sometimes we don't
and uh
and there we go
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one